a FICO score the algorithm that is used
to create your FICO score it's a
mathematical algorithm is 100% based on
you having some interaction with that
the type of debt you have the amount of
debt you have how you repay the debt the
speed at which you repay the debt all of
those kinds of things enter into your
FICO score so mathematically speaking a
FICO score is an I love debt score and
if you love debt a lot and you like
paying it on time a lot and often you'll
have a very high I love debt score which
means that other people that want to
loan you money will love you because you
love debt and they want you to get into
debt and so they love you so your I love
debt score is a wonderful thing to have
if you love debt now the trick is what
trap have you fallen into what's the
mythology that you've come to believe in
order to get into this crap the
mythology that you've come to believe is
is that debt is a way to become wealthy
that's the mythology the way I get stuff
I want and the life I want is by using
debt
well the borrower is slave to the lender
darling and when you pay out hundreds of
thousands of dollars for a false measure
of financial success you lose your
ability to win with money a FICO score
does not indicate you have a net worth
you could be given ten million dollars
tomorrow you could put it in them in
repaid for real estate and mutual funds
it won't change your FICO score one
point I know because my FICO score
doesn't exist it's zero I don't have a
FICO score why because I haven't
borrowed money haven't had any
interaction with debt in decades and if
I don't have any interaction with debt
you know that means I didn't pay the
bank interest it means I didn't have
somebody bearing down on me and getting
ready to foreclose on me I didn't have
anybody threatening to come take stuff
out of my house or threatening to take
my paycheck away I have a
been treated like a slave in a very long
time consequently since I don't love
debt my I love debt score is zero so
what's in your wallet Dave Money
different kind of question Thank You
Citibank and I don't need some Sheikh
dude walking down through some
commercial explaining to me how cool he
is cuz he's got a credit card
our based on the color of his plastic
that he's cool if your self-esteem is
based on the color of your plastic
you're what's known as stupid and
shallow do I need to repeat that was
that unclear if your self-esteem is
based on the color of your plastic
you're stupid and shallow you don't have
anything to base your self-esteem on
it's like basing your self-esteem on the
car you drive oh my gosh why would you
ever do that well I don't mind you're
getting a nice car but if that's what
you're all about if you're defined by
your vehicle well you're stupid and
shallow it's unbelievable
let me just tell you stupid and shallow
always equals broke too it always comes
with the territory
so decide what you want to be wealthy
our playing kissy-face with the bank for
the rest of your life I can't seem to
get ahead all I do is work just pay
payments I work for the man all the
money comes in all the money goes out
but I got a FICO score well that's
stupid no wonder you're a rat in a wheel
no wonder you work for the man cuz you
put yourself in bondage to the man so
break it baby get the credit cards out
and chop them up it's time for plastic
surgery it's time to decide the car
payment is the mantra of the
middle-class I'm not gonna have a car
payment any more I'm gonna own the
freakin car why is this hard this is the
Dave Ramsey show